dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I hear
scientists at Google just released the
translator Tron this is an AI that is
able to translate speech from one
language into speech into another
language and here comes the first twist
without using text as an intermediate
representation you give it the sound
waves and you get the translated sound
waves and this neural network was
trained approximately on a million voice
samples so let's see what learning on
this one million samples gives us listen
this is the input sentence in Spanish II
I'm a no school state P de and here it
is translated to English but using the
voice of the same person and you will
not know unless you ask
they have their say-so stop doing that
nuevos empleados de cranfield university
new hires at Cranfield University this
is incredible however there is another
twist perhaps an even bigger one believe
it or not this technique can not only
translate but also perform voice
transfer so it can say the same thing
using someone else's voice this means
that the AI not only has to learn what
to say but how to say it
this is immensely difficult it's also
not easy to know what we need to listen
to and when so let me walk you through
it this is a sentence in Spanish non
Archon Delphinus this is the same
sentence said by someone else an actual
person and in English swimming with
dolphins
and now the same thing but synthesized
by the algorithm using both of their
voices swimming with dolphins
swimming with dolphins let's listen to
them side-by-side some more swimming
with dolphins
swimming with dolphins this is so good
let's have a look at some more examples
por lo tanto madad alrededor del país
you look a mess so look around the
country and what do you see
so look around the country and what you
see
so look around the country and what you
see
Wow the method performs the learning by
trying to map these mouths spectrograms
between multiple speakers you can see
example sentences here and there
corresponding spectrograms which are
concise representations of someone's
voice and intonation and of course it is
difficult to mathematically formalise
what makes a good translation and a good
mimicking of someone's voice so in these
cases we'll let people be the judge and
have them listen to a few speech signals
and asking them to guess which was the
real person and which was the AI
speaking if you take a closer look at
the paper you will see that it smokes
the competition this is great progress
on an immensely difficult task as we
have to perform proper translation and
voice transfer at the same time it's
quite a challenge of course failure
cases still exist listen then she is a
la cosa dan yeah that's the thing
down yeah that's the thing
damn yeah that's the thing down yeah
that's the thing
damn yeah that's just imagine that you
are in a foreign country and all you
need to do is use your phone to test
stories to people not only in their own
language but also using your own voice
even if you don't speak a word of their
language beautiful even this video could
perhaps be available in a variety of
languages using my own voice within the
next few years although I wonder how
these algorithms would pronounce my name
so far that proved to be quite a
challenge for humans and a eyes are like
and for now all hail the mighty
translator Tron in the mean time I just
got back from this year's NATO
conference it was an incredible honor to
get an invitation to speak at such an
event and of course I was happy to
attend as a service to the public the
goal of the talk was to inform key
political and military decision-makers
about recent developments in AI so they
can make better decisions for us and I
was so nervous during the talk my
goodness if you wish to watch it I put a
link to it in the video description and
I may be able to upload a higher quality
version of this video here in the future
attending the conference introduced
delays in our schedule my apologies for
that and normally we would have to worry
whether because of this we'll have
enough income to improve our recording
equipment however with your support on
patreon this is not at all the case so I
want to send you a big thank you for all
your amazing support this was really all
possible thanks to you if you wish to
support us just go to
patreon.com/scishow to scripture have
fun with the video thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time